[Music]
hi martin are you busy i'm free
i was wondering if it's possible to call
a private cloud function from
a google compute engine instance uh yes
it is
i'll show you how
so dina out of curiosity why do you want
to know about calling a private cloud
function
okay after the big hr outage we had last
week
our manager wants us to move the on-prem
hr application to the cloud
and she wants us to re-architect it
using service-oriented architecture
i'm a little overwhelmed over where to
start
um i have a feeling we'll have to use
private cloud functions
okay let's think about it we have two
main challenges
how do we move the app to the cloud and
then how do we migrate
to a service oriented architecture right
but remember our hr application is
written in cobol
it's not exactly a runtime that cloud
providers usually cover
ah good point um i know
give me some mountain dew and six weeks
and i'll rewrite the whole thing in
python
i'm not sure that's a good idea
we know from the dora research that
applications are more stable
and have fewer incidents if we roll out
small changes frequently
six weeks of refactoring and one big
push
sounds like a recipe for a crash with
that many lines of code
how are you even going to isolate the
bugs and the system won't stand still in
the meantime
ah good point cooler heads prevail
oh here's another idea what if we load
the app
as is into a virtual machine and then we
peel off services
over time that we can put into google
cloud functions
for instance we could start with the
vacation requester
i love that idea i think it'll work
but we'll have to use private cloud
functions because
we don't want just anyone messing with
our vacation requests
okay so now i see why you want to
know how to get a virtual machine to
talk to a private cloud function
all right so our plan is to migrate the
app to
a virtual machine and then break out one
service to a cloud function
but first we need to validate that the
virtual machine is able to call
a private cloud function i say let's
test it out with the default hello world
function
and i can do a curl to the cloud
function url from the virtual machine
sounds good to me okay i will start by
making the cloud function
uh okay here we go create
and to be extra special sure i'm going
to set it to require
authentication we'll save that and
to internal traffic
only i want to use internal traffic only
to block any external requests
and i want to require authentication to
ensure no unauthorized internal apps
have
access to my service all right okay
sounds good
all right looks like your function
deployed and now click it and let's
check
the trigger link to make sure that it
denies
our request ah yes
it's blocking my request so we know
that our settings are working ah
an error message we wanted to see
excellent
so now uh let's send it some internal
traffic from a virtual machine
okay i'll create a new virtual machine
here we go create instance
um just leave all these defaults on
scroll to the bottom and i'm going to
use the default service account
why does it matter which service account
you use
oh good question um for the
authentication
we need to use a service account that
has permission to invoke our function
the default compute service account has
this by default if you're also using the
default settings
on the google cloud function side of
course these permissions are all
configurable
uh but we can talk about that another
time
got it okay i'm going to ssh
into it and try pinging my function
first i need my url
let's copy this copy link
and we're going to we're just going to
do a curl call here
curl
oh it's saying forbidden 403 error
ah right don't forget the authorization
header
oh yeah i forgot
okay so i'm going to run this again i'm
just going to add my authorization error
header it worked
so now you're able to call from a
virtual machine in your in the same
project if you have the authorization
header
now just to be sure let's try the same
command from your desktop machine
403 awesome we can access the function
from
inside the virtual machine but not from
the public internet
wonderful how would we do this from
inside an application
instead of using carl that's a great
question
for service to service requests we can
either write a direct call to the
metadata server
or we can use one of the google auth
client libraries which will construct
this call for you
the client libraries cover c-sharp go
java
node.js php python and ruby
amazing i think we have enough
information to make our project proposal
oh man i completely forgot about the
cobalt
oh we better get working on that
vacation requester
we're gonna need it after this
[Music]
you